what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and right now Marvel Studios is making a
lot of changes and they're making these
changes so the MCU can be better and
with that does come unfortunately some
delays and possibly even some
cancellations of some Disney Plus shows
possibly and the Sony Spider-Man
universe is also kind of connecting to
the MCU now with the latest trailer 4
across the spider-verse referencing the
events that happened in Spider-Man no
way home in the MCU possibly hinting at
a crossover in fact according to some
insiders yes we will see some of the
spider-verse characters in Avengers
Secret Wars but with all of this
happening I thought it would be a good
idea to go over every project that
Marvel Studios and Sony has coming up
because there's been a lot of confusion
lately with the delays and possible
canceling of shows plus we have some
rumored Disney plus special
presentations and Disney Plus shows and
movies coming up so we'll talk about
those as well there's a lot there's over
40 different projects that Marvel
Studios and Sony have coming up but
first for the comic book fans I want to
tell you about my buddies over at
comicbookdirect.com they have created a
website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below so we'll start with the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and work our
way to the Sony spiderverse and I think
a lot of people know about the most
recent upcoming MCU movies the next
project that we have coming out for the
MCU is Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3
this is indeed going to be the last
Guardians movie with this specific team
not the last Guardians of the Galaxy
movie ever but the current team that we
have right now in the MCU it's the last
movie for them and James Gunn and most
of the cast have already confirmed this
be prepared for this movie as it comes
out on May 5th 2023 not that far from
now then we have secret Invasion after
that and the recent trailer showed us
that this show looks to be pretty dang
awesome it's about Nick Fury Maria Hill
Everett Ross the scroll Talos and many
many other awesome characters fighting a
scroll resistance the scroll have
infiltrated major and Powerful
organizations all around the world
threatening the world as we know it and
this is apparently going to be Nick
Fury's final fight but we'll wait and
see on that one then of course we have
Loki season two now this was supposed to
come out summer of 2023 and now it's
looking like it's going to come out a
little bit later in the summer maybe
just right after summer in 2023 and this
is going to show us Loki and Owen
Wilson's character Mobius following and
hunting down Kang the Conqueror trying
to stop the huge multiversal war and
ultimately the destruction of the
universe then we have the Marvels which
is going to feature Captain Marvel
Kamala Khan as Miss Marvel and Monica
Rambo now not much is really known about
this movie what we know is that Carol
Danvers Kamala Khan and Monica Rambo
begin swapping places with each other
every time that they use their powers
and they must team up to determine why
and this comes out November 10th of
2023. then we have the X-Men 97 Animated
Series right now currently scheduled for
fall of 2023. in this series the humans
are actually going to be on the side of
the mutant so Magneto steps in and
becomes the leader of the X-Men trying
to do right by Charles Xavier however Mr
Sinister has other plans then we have
another animated series what if season 2
that is kind of up in the air right now
this could come out in 2023 or in 2024
we do not have a release date for this
yet but it's pretty much going to be
exactly like the first season then we
have the echo series and we don't have a
release date for this yet either it
could come out this year towards the end
or next year in 2024. this series will
be about Maya Lopez who we met in the
Hawkeye series and it will also feature
Daredevil and Kingpin then we have the
Iron Heart series which I've actually
heard good things about recently but we
don't have an official release date for
this yet either could be the end of this
year or 2024 and this will follow Riri
Williams who we met in Black Panther
wakanda forever as she becomes ironheart
the villain of this series will be the
hood and it's been rumored that Mephisto
could pop up in the series as well then
we have Agatha coven of chaos which I'm
personally extremely excited for we'll
get to know a little bit more about
Agatha Harkness and it's said that
Elizabeth Olsen will indeed cameo in
this as well as the Scarlet Witch no
official release date for this but it
will come in Winter of 2023 or winter of
2024. then we have Daredevil Born Again
Charlie Cox is returning as Daredevil
Matt Murdoch this time in the MCU
Vincent D'Onofrio will be returning to
the MCU as well as Kingpin Marvel has
confirmed this will be 18 episodes long
and will continue much like the Netflix
series to be pretty violent this is set
to come out in early of 2024. then we
have Captain America New World Order now
sadly William Hurt who played
Thunderbolt Ross has passed away so
Harrison Ford is now playing Thunderbolt
Ross in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and from what we know he is going to be
the president in Captain America New
World Order and possibly even Hulk out
as the Red Hulk and we've heard that
there are going to be some other
iterations of Hulk in this film as well
it's also been said that this movie will
set up the new Avengers team in the MCU
then heavily connecting with this movie
is going to be the Thunderbolts team
which is said to feature and introduce
Sentry into the MCU a big rumored plot
of this is that they're going to be
searching for adamantium which is what
the metal inside of Wolverine is made of
I've heard that this is the craziest
script that Marvel has ever written so
I'm really excited about this one then
we have blade which is currently set for
September 6th of 2024. now we don't
really know anything about this movie
except it's going to Star mahershala Ali
as blade they had to rewrite basically
the entire movie because the first
script was terrible so really not much
details are known about this but it is
going to be a major movie for the
supernatural side of the MCU then of
course we have Deadpool 3 featuring Ryan
Reynolds and freaking Hugh Jackman
returning as Wolverine now in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what we know is that
Deadpool and Wolverine are basically
going to be traveling the Multiverse
together in a joyride a road trip
between two best friends and honestly
this is what we wanted Ryan Reynolds as
Deadpool and Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
together just fighting each other
fighting other people we really don't
care at this point because we got our
wish of the two of them being together
this movie is said to have a lot of
original X-Men cameos from the fox
franchise and ultimately end up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe then we have
Spider-Man freshman year this does not
have an official release date yet but it
is set for 2024. this animated series is
going to follow Peter Parker on his way
to becoming Spider-Man in the MCU with a
journey unlike we've ever seen in a
style that celebrates the character's
early comic book Roots according to
Disney so yes this should be the same
exact Peter Parker that is Tom Holland's
Spider-Man in the MCU this is simply
going to be the origin story that we
never saw on screen then we have a movie
that everyone is super excited for the
Fantastic Four in the MCU now according
to some insiders the Fantastic Four
might have already been cast at least
Sue storm and Reed Richards however we
do not know the cast of The Fantastic
Four yet even if they've been cast we
don't know who they are unfortunately
the movies release date got pushed back
a few months to February 14th of 2025.
they recently got a new writer for the
film because they wanted it to be even
better than it already so make no
mistake Kevin foggy the president of
Marvel Studios is making sure that this
movie is fantastic then we have our next
Avengers film Avengers the Kang Dynasty
coming out May 2nd of
2025. from what we know this will take
place primarily on our main Earth and
our main universe but will most likely
end with Kang winning and the Avengers
losing and the Multiverse basically
going into chaos this will directly lead
into Avengers Secret Wars which will be
a huge multiversal film and this film
will feature the old Fox X-Men different
versions of the Fantastic Four including
the old versions of the Fantastic Four
that we've seen variants of characters
that we know and love perhaps we'll even
finally see that Tom Cruise Superior
Iron Man but make no mistake about it
Marvel Studios is planning on this to be
the biggest superhero movie of all time
and that does it for everything with an
official release date but we have plenty
of more projects that have been
announced by Marvel Studios or that have
been announced by insiders or trade
companies like deadline or The Hollywood
Reporter that are coming up and have
been confirmed that don't have release
dates yet and we'll jump into those now
now the first one that I know everybody
is wondering about is the new Spider-Man
movie Spider-Man 4 Marvel Studios and
Sony did already announce that they are
in fact working on Spider-Man 4. and
according to some Insider reports Tom
Holland has signed a six movie deal or a
six project deal to be Spider-Man again
in the MCU three of those will be solo
Spider-Man movies the new MCU Trilogy
then two of those are going to be four
Avengers King Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars and then one more that we
don't know yet but probably for another
team-up project Spider-Man 4 is expected
to release either before the Kang
Dynasty or before Avengers Secret Wars
then we know that doctor strange 3 is
supposed to come out before Avengers
Secret Wars as well obviously like the
end of Doctor Strange 2 LED off this is
going to involve clear and fixing some
incursions that happen which is going to
be a major plot point of Secret Wars so
we can assume that this is going to come
out probably in 2025 before 4 Secret
Wars maybe in between King Dynasty and
Secret Wars we also know that there is
supposed to be an eternals too however
this is kind of up in the air right now
we haven't gotten any confirmations from
Marvel Studios about anything relating
to the eternals 2 but they did set up
the movie and they did set up Star Fox
and pip the troll to appear in eternals
2. then of course we have the infamous
Young Avengers project obviously Marvel
Studios has been setting up Young
Avengers in the MCU however they have
said that they aren't doing a Young
Avengers film but according to some
insiders that is correct they are simply
going to call the Young Avengers film
Avengers Children's Crusade and that
will feature some of the older Avengers
but it is basically a Young Avengers
film nonetheless then we have a rumored
Moon Knight season 2 this has not been
confirmed really by anybody but it is
expected to happen the eternals also set
up kit harington's the Black Knight
where unsure if this is going to be a
solo project or if he's going to appear
in another movie like blade or another
Supernatural movie then we have Vision
Quest which we don't know a ton about
yet we do know of course it's going to
be about Vision but we are assuming it's
going to be about spectral Vision we met
in one division no release date at all
mentioned for this yet then we have
armor Wars this was originally supposed
to be a Disney plus series but it is now
being made into a movie of course this
will star Don Cheadle as Roadie AKA War
Machine and what we know is it's about
what happens when Iron Man technology
gets into the wrong hands and there's
even a rumor that Ultron could possibly
make his return in this movie no release
date but it could be expected at the end
of 2024 maybe early 2025. then we have
some wakanda series coming these are
going to be directed by Ryan coogler as
well Marvel has confirmed this and there
are going to be actually several wakanda
series not just one we don't really know
much about any of them except the fact
that akoi is going to have her own
series but we don't have release dates
for any of them then we have Marvel
Zombies this is going to be an animated
series that's going to pretty much be
what we saw on the what if Zombies
episode again no release date for this
but it is stated that it could come out
in 2024. then we have Shang Chi 2. now
there is no release date for this yet
although it is rumored to be coming out
before either Kang Dynasty or Secret
Wars because the plot of the movie is
said to be pretty important for the
upcoming Secret Wars film especially
since the 10 rings are most likely Kang
technology so we are probably looking at
a 2025 release date before Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars come out then we have
the Wonder Man series and Wonder Man
himself is going to be played by Yaya
Abdul Mateen II and it's rumored that
Ben Kingsley is going to be returning as
Trevor we did see him and Shang ching
The Legend of the 10 rings so it doesn't
surprise me that he'll show up in the
MCU again no release date for this but
production is set to begin pretty soon
for this project so I would say it'll
come out within the next couple of years
probably looking at 2025. now we get
into the more rumored side of things
projects that have been announced by
insiders these include a lot of specials
on Disney plus right now it's rumored
that we'll get a Mephisto special a
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday 2
special a Swamp Thing special a Silver
Surfer special which should come out
before the Fantastic Four movie so if
this is true we could be getting this
late 2024 and to top it all off a Nova
special which has been confirmed by
Major trade companies like deadline
however we do not have any type of
release date attached to that and those
are our MCU films let's now jump over to
the Sony spider-verse movies because of
course they are still Marvel projects
and some of them might actually bleed
into the MCU now of course we have
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
coming very soon in June of 2023 this
year and then we have beyond the
spider-verse which is going to be coming
out March 29th of 2024 and Beyond the
spot spider-verse could possibly connect
to the MCU in live action form this is
what is being speculated because of that
title beyond the spider-verse and like I
mentioned the trailer for across the
spiderverse did mention events that
happened in the MCU then we have Craven
the hunter this is going to be coming in
October 2023 and Russell Crowe has
recently said that this movie is
actually going to be dark then we have
again what is a weird Choice by Sony El
muerto coming in January of 2024 and he
is going to be played by Bad Bunny then
a very important movie for the Sony
spider-verse Madam Webb coming in
February of 2024. in the comics Madam
Webb is a cosmic entity who can travel
the Multiverse and based off of what we
know this is sort of going to be a time
travel movie Multiverse movie so this
could really really set up and dive deep
into the live-action spider verse for
Sony then it was announced by deadline
that we are going to be getting a silk
series called spider Society in the this
has been ordered by Amazon no release
date for this yet but it is in the works
with Sony and Amazon right now then of
course we have venom 3 Tom Hardy's last
film as Venom and we assume that this is
going to be an October release date of
2024 and Tom Hardy has very heavily
hinted that this movie is going to show
his Venom going up against Spider-Man so
fingers crossed for that then we have
Hypno Hustler which is another confusing
Choice by Sony but Donald Glover is
going to be playing Hypno Hustler which
I am excited about no type of release
date attached to this whatsoever then we
have our Spider Woman movie this is
going to be directed by Olivia Wilde
this movie is confirmed although we
don't really know much about it
including when this could possibly be
coming but we know of another Amazon
series that was ordered by Sony and that
is a Spider-Man Noir series and to top
it all off we have projects that are
going to be about Black Cat and another
project that is going to be about silver
Sable and that does it for all of the
Marvel projects that are coming out go
ahead and let us know your thoughts
about all of these in the comments down
below and let us know which ones are
your favorite what are you most looking
forward to please give the video a like
and don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all things happening
with Marvel both in the MCU and the Sony
spiderverse don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf